here's sean payton talking about his
team's quarterback situation post drew
brees
i think the furthest we went with that
would have been
you know when everyone was healthy and
taysom was playing
oh call it eight to ten plays maybe a
quarterback i i would never
discount that but i would say this
you know he knows
and and so does james that we're looking
to find the guy that's going to lead our
team this year
and that doesn't mean the other player
is not going to have a role but
certainly it varies you know if if jamis
is starting obviously taysom has a role
that expands not only just offensively
but on special teams etc
and if it's the other way around it's
probably a little bit more limited
uh
just relative to to what jameis would do
and then that transition
has begun and
you know we we look at them a lot of
what we're going to do offensively based
on who's doing it and how do we put an
offense around those players or that
players
that was specifically payton talking
about the possibility of using both
quarterbacks taysom hill and jameis
winston so look i think the goal is they
want one guy and peyton acknowledged
that they don't want to have rotating
quarterbacks you could have a taysom
hill package if jameis winston is the
starter
and i guess you could have a jameis
winston package if taysom hill is the
starter but they want a starter they're
not going to go with a two quarterback
platoon system
one of these guys is going to step up
and win that job it's either going to be
winston or it's going to be hill and you
could make the argument for either guy
and and we'll we'll see what happens
hill did pretty well last year when drew
brees was injured winston had his
moments too when he had a chance to play
including the touchdown pass on the
gimmick play in the playoff game against
the buccaneers so uh that's gonna be one
of the most fascinating camp battles
we've seen in a while peter who emerges
between hill and winston as the
successor to drew brees
you know if
if i had to
you know if i had to guess right now i'd
bet i'd guess winston
um and it's gonna be all it's gonna be
all up to uh winston
and how he takes care of the football
both in practice and whenever he plays
in the preseason games
because it's clear
you know i remember somebody very close
to sean payton when this happened when
they signed jameis winston
and i expressed a slight surprise
at you know the saints finding enough
money in the couch cushions you know
when they were very much against the cap
you know that they found a million bucks
or whatever it was to sign jameis
winston
and you know and i was told at the time
that
he will last five minutes
if he in new orleans with sean payton if
he turns it over
so to me i think sean payton is looking
at this as
i've given the guy
one year and drew brees has given the
guy one year brees really liked jameis
winston jameis winston loved drew brees
and
he learned a lot from brees and that one
of the big things i'm told he learned
mike is
learn how to fight another day you know
in other words
don't make a stupid decision that's
going to cost your team a turnover and
so those are the kind of things that
we'll see
if jameis winston has learned that and
we'll see if he's gotten significantly
markedly better i'm not naive enough to
say that just because he played for the
saints for a year and he learned under
peyton and brees that he's not going to
turn it over anymore that's that's silly
so if he proves he's not going to turn
it over anymore i think he'll be the guy
but he's got to prove it
well and and in fairness to jameis
winston
his five years before coming to new
orleans with sean payton and drew brees
consisted of dirk cutter who no one
should ever confuse with bill walsh and
mr no risk it no biscuit bruce aryans he
doesn't care about turnovers unless you
have too many of them then you're out
the door no risk it no biscuit now he's
with peyton and bree here's about three
interceptions though yes yes but when
brees retired jameis winston had a
session with the media visibly emotional
about drew brees yeah so this is a guy
who was the undisputed first overall
pick in the draft we knew the buccaneers
wanted him they tanked for him week 17
of the 2014 season it's proven it's
established it's factual they wanted him
instead of marcus mariota not that
either guy ended up being a franchise
quarterback but he came into the league
with high expectations he's yet to fully
live up to them but peter in the year
that he did have 30 interceptions he
also became one of the few guys in
league history to throw for 5 000 yards
every other guy who's done it
is either in the hall of fame on his way
to the hall of fame has an argument for
the hall of fame jameis winston's the
one guy that stands out as who doesn't
belong and why
but
you yeah look this this would be the
ultimate reclamation project for sean
payton if he turns jameis winston into
the guy he was supposed to be coming out
of florida state
i mean he might be able to do that um
and i think a little more highly
of
the coaches that uh
that jameis winston had than you do mike
i think he you're entitled to you're
entitled to your opinion uh aaron's yes
cutter don't get me started on dirk
cutter but aryans yes but but he but but
let's just talk about quarterback
coaching with dirk cutter okay not head
coaching those are two different things
i remember when jameis winston went in
for his
uh
you know pre-draft visit to tampa and he
sat down with dirk cutter
dirk cutter noticed that i forget how
many interceptions he threw his last
year at florida state 14 17 i forget
what number it was
but
he at one point jameis winston said to
dirk cutter i've got confidence i can
make every throw
and dirk cutter said to him in essence
well it's good to have that confidence
but i'm looking at some of these throws
and you shouldn't have made them
you know so maybe you shouldn't be all
that confident about throw x y and z you
know where you throw it into really
tight coverage and you throw it right to
the defense
so i think dirk cutter was was hard on
jameis winston at you know at the
requisite times and his message just
didn't get through would that have
gotten through with peyton
in those five years who knows maybe yes
but
i think that it's faulty logic to say
that
he went to the wrong team to cure his
turnover itis
i think you know he we don't know that
and if sean payton does fix him now
then you know we'll tip the cap to sean
payton but i think that he's he has to
show that he can do it mike
when cutter became the head coach
probably less hands-on coaching of
jameis winston it reminds me what
happened in cleveland when freddie
kitchens became the head coach and was
no longer coaching baker mayfield
directly mayfield went off the rails in
2019 the other reality is this
i think we can agree sean payton one of
the finest quarterback coaches in the
history of the game other than andy reid
right now i can't imagine another guy
who
winston would be in as good of a
position with and obviously
reid's got his quarterback for the
foreseeable future and beyond peyton
doesn't and and this is his chance and
and it's a great you know
styles go ahead
you know what else he has
he has an offense with a truly great
wide receiver a truly great running back
and uh two really good tackles
okay so i mean and look the saints are
in the
not rebuilding phase
of their post-breeze life because they
can still be really good
but they have a lot of offensive
elements
you know you look at traequan smith even
they have a lot of offensive elements
that i believe are really good and just
add qb
is really what they need to do and we're
gonna see if winston can take advantage
of that
and the last point in this regard sean
payton will not hesitate to make a
change if whoever wins that job as of
week one isn't performing to his
satisfaction that pressure will be there
from week one through week 18. still
we're weird to say week 18 but there
will be 18 weeks for whoever starts to
falter and possibly yield to the other
guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports